[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a escala en París un
programa semanal de radio Francia
internacional en colaboración con la
televisión France 24 en español en el
que cada semana damos la palabra
personas del mundo de las ciencias las
artes la cultura los deportes la
política y claro está de la sociedad
civil en diciembre del año pasado el
presidente del Perú Pedro Castillo
intentó disolver el parlamento de ese
país añadiendo una nueva crisis a la
crisis que atravesaba el país andino a
seis meses de distancia esa crisis sigue
sin cerrarse qué evaluación puede
hacerse de esa situación Cuál es la
situación de la población Cuál es la
relación que mantiene el gobierno
peruano con alguno de sus países
latinoamericanos y vecinos de esa región
para hablar de ello nos acompaña hoy el
presidente del Consejo de ministros de
Perú el señor Alberto otarola señor
Primer Ministro Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos bienvenido Gracias
señor Primer Ministro usted está aquí
haciendo escala en París viene a una
reunión de la organización de la
cooperación y desarrollo económico la
ocde para formalizar la solicitud de
ingreso de Perú a ese organismo
considerado como el club de los países
más ricos del mundo y el de la buena
gobernanza En qué fase está esa
situación bueno hemos venido una ha
venido una delegación de alto nivel en
la que también me acompañan el ministro
de economía y la ministra de relaciones
exteriores lo que expresa el alto
interés de Perú no solamente por
ingresar al mecanismo de la ocde sino
también por exponer Y conversar con las
autoridades francesas y por supuesto con
las comisiones de esta altísima
institución respecto de la posibilidad y
la certeza que tenemos de ingresar este
mecanismo que nos va a permitir dos
cosas muy puntuales
culminar un proceso de reformas
institucionales para asegurar una
gobernanza más asertiva que nos permita
darle servicios públicos de calidad a
los ciudadanos peruanos Y en segundo
lugar relanzar la posición del Perú
en su relación con Europa y con el mundo
a de la gestión pública y la retoma de
la Reforma política que es lo que nos
interesa como peruanos y como como país
estamos exponiendo en el mundo hay que
recordar simplemente que hasta ahora
solo cuatro países de América Latina
hacen parte de ese organismo en orden de
incorporación son México Chile Colombia
y Costa Rica Alberto otarola lo decíamos
en la introducción la crisis política se
produjo o se aceleró con el intento del
expresidente Pedro castillo de disolver
El parlamento su reemplazo a no ha
cerrado podríamos decir esa crisis sea
al contrario se puede decir que se ha
profundizado en una cierta medida a seis
meses de distancia de ese intento
fallido de disolución del parlamento de
manera breve Cómo define la situación
que atravesó oipe no dos precisiones no
hubo ningún intento dio un golpe de
estado el señor Castillo que ahora está
en prisión por serias acusaciones de
corrupción tiene 19 colaboradores
eficaces que señalan que él o su entorno
ha recibido dinero y lo segundo la
crisis ya conclu en el país el país ha
entrado un proceso de pacificación en
este momento no existe una sola marcha
de protesta ninguna ningún camino
bloqueado porque con mucho esfuerzo en
estos seis meses hoy día cumplimos seis
meses en la gestión de la presidenta
boluarte hemos dado a los 33 millones de
peruanos el derecho constitucional a la
paz y a la tranquilidad y estamos en ese
proceso gobernando con paz con
tranquilidad y habiendo superado un
lamentable suceso en la historia
reciente de nuestro país habla usted que
el país está pacificado el día de ayer
la presidenta diluna buluarte fue
audicionada por las autoridades
judiciales para testimoniar en una
acusación por homicidio y por genocidio
son los cargos que se juzgan hay que
recordar que las protestas seguidos a lo
que usted llama un intento de golpe de
estado dejaron un golpe de estado fueron
60 muertos oficialmente exactamente
ahora la pregunta es En dónde está esa
fase la presidenta dice que no sabía
nada de lo que sucedió fue las
declaraciones que hizo ayer que no tiene
responsabilidad no obstante lo que
registraron los medios en su momento Es
que la presidenta felicitó incluso a las
fuerzas armadas por la acción que había
llevado durante las protestas que
siguieron a la destitución del
presidente aquí ha habido dos dos temas
muy muy importantes en primer lugar
el ataque permanente de un grupo muy
pequeño muy violento y financiado por el
narcotráfico y la minería ilegal que
pretendió tomar el poder porque ya
tenían el gobierno y soliviantar el
estado constitucional de derecho en el
país lo que ha funcionado es la
institucionalidad democrática aquellas
instituciones que Pedro Castillo quiso
cerrar el tribunal constitucional no
solo congreso la fiscalía de la nación
quiso capturar arrestar a la fiscal de
la nación que lo investigaba El Congreso
de la República la junta Nacional de
Justicia todos estos organismos cerraron
filas con el estado de derecho en el
Perú y formularon lo que se conoce como
la sucesión constitucional que es el
gobierno en este momento legítimamente
viene ejerciendo la presidenta boluarte
sobre lo segundo
hemos llorado y lamentado la pérdida de
Vidas de muchos compatriotas pero esa
esa ese contexto se realizó en el en el
escenario de un ataque contra las
instituciones del estado cinco
aeropuertos con intento de toma de
manera simultánea hasta que desarmados
contra las fuerzas del orden en
consecuencia los fallecidos digamos la
responsabilidad política por lo que ha
pasado a Perú es el señor Castillo no de
Dina boluarte y lo que ha ocurrido ayer
el Ministerio Público es lo que tiene
que hacer un presidente un gobernante
con con alta responsabilidad ellos
mismos nosotros mismos hemos pedido que
se investigue nos hemos puesto a
disposición de la Fiscalía de la nación
Y eso es lo que está ocurriendo en el
Perú en este momento no obstante usted
dice que el país está pacificado lo que
sale en la prensa es que está anunciada
ya una tercera toma de la Ciudad de Lima
no sabemos que va a dar esto
evidentemente Más allá de esto señor
Primer Ministro lo que me interesa a mí
es lo siguiente Dina boluarte es la
sexta presidenta y la primera mujer
presidenta en Perú es una cosa
interesante es la presidenta que se
sucede sabiendo que los cinco
presidentes que la han antecedido todos
están acusados de corrupción algunos
están en prisión incluso alguno se
suicidó Mi pregunta es qué está fallando
en el país usted me dice que hay una
normalización Qué falla de que el uno
tras otro los mandatarios que se han
sucedido estos últimos años en Perú
acaban seguidos por la justicia por
corrupción u otros cargos creo que ha
habido dos elementos el primero digamos
una una protesta legítima contra todo lo
que significa estado dio mucha demagogia
en el en la asignación de las obras
públicas en la promesa sin cumplida no
digamos demagogia que se incrementó en
el año y medio en el que estuvo el señor
Castillo como presidente y creo que
también tenemos un problema en cuanto a
la concepción de nuestro modelo político
hoy en día nuestro modelo es híbrido
presidencial para lamentario el gabinete
tiene que ir a pedir la confianza al
congreso y el congreso y el presidente
puede disolver el congreso Y eso no ha
permitido tener una estabilidad política
y que creo es una tarea pendiente que
tendrá que acometer el congreso en este
momento que es la herencia de la
Constitución que se creó en los años 90
es la herencia de la Constitución de
1993 Constitución que dicho sea de paso
nos ha permitido ser los líderes en el
crecimiento de América Latina hoy día en
este momento El Perú es el país que más
ha crecido en América Latina vamos a
tener un 3% de crecimiento tenemos la
inflación más baja en América Latina la
las expectativas por invertir en minería
han crecido en 6% acabamos de suscribir
una una emisión en la bolsa de valores
hemos tocado la campana en Wall Street y
todo esto en los seis meses de gobierno
la presidenta boluarte Aunque la
inestabilidad sigue ha regresado la
estabilidad al país y estamos preparados
para poder gobernar en la en la en los
meses siguientes asegurando No solamente
la protección de los Derechos a la
integridad de la vida y a la paz y a la
prosperidad de los peruanos sino
retomando el liderazgo que el Perú ha
tenido América Latina en materia
económica Alberto tarola ustedes más
instante la responsabilidad del
presidente del expresidente Castillo
está Clara una violación precisa de la
Constitución que explican que siga en
prisión de que haya sido condenado a
dieciocho meses de precisión es tan
lenta la justicia cuanto tiene el caso
de un presidente que está acusado
directamente y no se le puede juzgar
antes Bueno es lo que han determinado
los jueces en el Perú la justicia es
independiente en el caso de Castillo fue
apresado por el delito de sedición y
rebelión pero luego esa acusación Y esa
prisión preventiva Se ratificó por los
cuestionamientos o las acusaciones que
tiene por corrupción El Señor está preso
para decirle una sola palabra por
corrupto no Entonces nosotros Esperamos
que eso se resuelva es lamentable que
tengamos tantos presidentes en esa sin
duda no es para nada lagüeña para
nuestro país pero lo repito la justicia
tiene que hacer su trabajo Mientras
tanto hemos pasado la página y estamos
gobernando hacia adelante Usted estuvo
la semana Hace unos días atrás en en
Brasil perdón a invitación del
presidente células da Silva que riñó a
los países de la unasur reunión de
Naciones de América del Sur El objetivo
del presidente Lula así lo señaló era de
relanzar reanimar ese organismo que fue
creado en 2008 yo quisiera preguntarle
primero Cuál es su apreciación de la
reunión Cuál es la posición de su
gobierno respecto a esta iniciativa del
gobierno brasileño fue una reunión muy
buena era imprescindible que nuevamente
tengamos una visión de conjuntos sobre
América del Sur al Perú particularmente
le interesa la amazonía el río Amazonas
es esta larga Avenida que recorre tres
cuartas partes de Sudamérica y que se
inicia en el Perú a cinco mil
trescientos metros en Arequipa y que
salió muy afectada absolutamente
afectado porque tenemos problemas
nosotros tenemos cincuenta y tres
nacionalidades
50 idiomas más de cuatro millones de
peruanos vive en la amazonía el 60% del
territorio peruano es amazónico entonces
y estamos preocupados por la minería
ilegal por la presencia del narcotráfico
por la desprotección de las comunidades
nativas por la
compleja digamos depredación de los
bosques tropicales en en en la amazonía
y es por eso que hemos venido acá a
Europa hemos tenido reuniones en con las
autoridades españolas asesoramiento con
las autoridades francesas para plantear
en esta Cumbre que va a haber próxima
Unión Europea con celac la visión y en
eso coincidimos con el presidente Lula
Silva de darle un tratamiento especial y
una mirada global a la amazonía para su
defensa y promoción Cuáles son las
propuestas que va a llevar van a llevar
en este caso creo que tenemos que tener
un trabajo muy concreto sobre el medio
ambiente de la amazonía tenemos que
relanzar las relaciones de Europa con
América Latina desde el 2015 no se lleva
a cabo una reunión conjunta nos parece a
los latinoamericanos por lo menos en el
Perú que Europa ha desviado la mirada de
América Latina y es hora de volver a
enfocarla en nuestra región por varias
razones por el relanzamiento que tenemos
en el caso de Perú de nuestra economía y
la necesidad de digamos poder convocar a
las inversiones europeas para un
ambicioso proyecto de cierre de brechas
de infraestructura que va a ser como de
40 mil millones de dólares en el país y
sobre todo para tener una visión
estratégica respecto al rol que América
Latina cumple dentro del contexto de la
globalidad hay mucha inversión de China
una versión sostenida en América Latina
y creemos que Europa tiene que regresar
la mirada no solamente para digamos
volver a invertir en en nuestros países
sino también para tener alianzas
estratégicas en temas muy concretos como
el que acabo de mencionar el tema de la
amazonia ha sido ya desplazado incluso
la Unión Europea como segundo principal
inversor de América Latina piensa usted
que todavía tiene lugar para que ella
restablezca o
reemplace en un correcto lugar como
inversionista y bueno creo fundamental
para América Latina Perú el principal
socio en este momento para las
inversiones es Gran Bretaña se dio
España creemos que Francia también puede
hacer mucho más en nuestro país tenemos
un inmenso proyecto de infraestructura
con Francia que es la carretera central
que es un mega proyecto que construir en
cinco años la Nueva carretera central en
el Perú y creemos que por los lazos
históricos de amistad y sobre todo por
las relaciones que siempre hemos tenido
con Europa nosotros reclamamos un lugar
en la mesa para poder dialogar
democráticamente y poder discutir sobre
nuestros problemas pero también sobre
nuestro futuro pues estamos llegando ya
al final de esta escala en París no me
queda sino agradecerle al presidente del
Consejo de ministros de Perú Alberto
otarola su presencia en esta escala en
París Muchísimas gracias señor
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes les damos
una nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en París
[Música]
[Aplausos]